ja einmal bitte warten natürlich wir
werden jetzt hier was auslegen und um
die halle zu kümmern danke dann werden
wir uns morgen geheilt zu kommen was
muss man als erstes machen
zuerst mal den ball auch nach dem
ausschalten haushalten die heizung aus
werden wir unten war
wir machen uns mal angucken wieder drin
raum aussieht
du holst jetzt bitte mal den staubsauger
ja und dann werden wir mal den brenner
raus
[Musik]
es ist immer werden wir den asche
behälter aus lernt
[Musik]
und wer das gehst du bitte mal den
messkopf vom auto in der klammer gibt es
nur wird das match gewählt
[Applaus]
was gibt es denn für eine obergrenze für
den ceo wird beim terror wird ist es so
dass wir möglichst tief sein sollte in
der regel also bei 15 ok aber wenn er
dann höre schießen sollte auf bis über
500 dann wird die anlage so vorstelle
gelegt weil das schädliche oder in zu
hoher konzentration in die luft kommt
okay aber das hier das passt
wir haben ihre heizung beraten nach der
heizung muss alles in ordnung
ich habe hier unseren zettel
fertiggemacht
die anlage gewartet wir haben auch die
abgase gemessen das passt alles gut dann
müssen sie sich keine sorgen machen
und da bekomme ich bitte von ihnen dort
eine unterschiedliche super danke ich
wünsche ihnen auch nicht verabschieden